this is me the lost and forgotten Jane  anything like to share move leave my  home no I'm good  welcome to life house a home for the  broken  the sad and the suffering I'm gonna miss  you know you can come visit me I've  always been good at lying I heard the  good news that's all around them to be  away from home you must be excited yeah  thanks  but the pain will burying hey I'm Paul  it's never going away it's when I get on  that plane at night  this is me  arrived home no one knows the path our  lives will take we can't stay here we  have to calm down  just go no one's coming to get us  I'm in that no no we're here together I  think to know you're not going to tap  out  I promise don't tap out on me  you